there are five major energy sources in
the world right now petroleum natural
gas coal renewable energy and nuclear
power thanks to the US shale and
fracking boom and the fact that it is
now cheap plentiful and clean its
natural gas that may be the fuel of the
future big oil companies are using a
technology that turns it into liquefied
natural gas or LNG a commodity that can
be shipping all over the world reshaping
the politics of global energy so here's
the situation the trickiest problem with
natural gas right now is right there in
the name it's a gas most gas travels
through pipelines that makes it fairly
difficult if the US wants to sell its
gas to say Korea but a few things make
shipping natural gas possible first is
the process of super cooling natural gas
to minus 260 degrees Fahrenheit
converting it to a liquid and reducing
its volume by about 600 times it's like
going from a beach ball to a ping-pong
ball this makes it possible to transport
gas not through pipelines but on really
big ships which leads us to a fleet of
250 million dollar tankers some the size
of almost four American football fields
that can ferry LNG all over the world
the only problem is these ships were too
big to fit through the Panama Canal
until now the five billion dollar Panama
Canal expansion project was finally
finished in June 2016 allowing for
faster shipping of LNG to key markets
like Asia so what does this mean for
global energy well a growing number of
countries are trading in LNG with 34
nations importing it by the end of 2014
compared to just 15 in 2005 now here's
the argument overall demand for LNG
depends on how fast countries will turn
away from coal the largest source of
power generation in the world one LNG
selling point is that it's cleaner
producing about half as much carbon
dioxide as coal oil companies are
pushing into the LNG world to embrace a
greener future Shell's fifty three
billion dollar acquisition of UK oil and
producer BG group the industry's biggest
deal in a decade made the Dutch giant
the world's largest LNG trader but not
everyone's aboard the LNG trade hole is
still cheaper renewables pollute less
and countries like Japan the largest
importer of LNG in the world is focused
on nuclear power after starting to get
its reactors back up and running after
shutdowns prompted by the 2011 tsunami
plus some US gas utilities are opposed
to large-scale exports of LNG saying
that longer term it can raise gas prices
for American consumers